always a fun player to watch Chuck you
definitely brought a fun to the game but
didn't score as many points as you would
like how do you rate your performance
not only in this tournament but in the
grand chess tour
of course of course it was not very good
tournaments for me I mean all two limits
I played not very well uh I think it's a
big problem for me so I played too much
this year and I just was very tight I
missed many
moves many games and in this tournament
and it was last for me I mean last like
uh
last thing is how I lose is how there is
a I mean absolutely a very good position
I lose in two moves or three maybe
uh because uh it's very strange for me I
I think I just was very tired and I miss
I blundered too much
uh you said that you're tired you've
been playing a lot of tournaments not
only the grand Chester you of course
also played the Olympiad uh what are you
gonna do in the next few months will you
also have a full schedule of tournaments
or will you take some rest
okay I have some contracts tournaments
of course I will play all my tournaments
which I agreed but
it's a problem really I played too much
I say I mean I calculate
I mean just two weeks ago I will play in
this year about rapid classical and is
like Magnus tour is all together it's
about 300 games and just classical and
Rapid without planting Bloods rapid
pre-time and also is
rapid and I played only grantor builds
rapid and also Magnus tour I think four
tournaments or three or four tournaments
and also I played in classical chess
about the 1775 games it's also yeah I
mean you play every time in the very
high level every time is your offense is
very strong
and after some moments I just play I
just play any moves in opening because
everything is finished and no home
preparation is like Hotel preparations
absolutely very bad
the openings and I will try not to eat
till next year and I will try to next
year to play not too much like this year
I just relax preparing for chess and
enjoy from Life do you feel that this is
one of the main differences between you
and this teenage players who never run
out of energy I mean normally I never
miss or play like I played against
others are I mean I got a very good
adventure and I just losing three moves
and normally you know I I miss this
every move for after take porn I I don't
know I mean it's just it is only my
fault I mean this is because when it was
covet we not play chess after covet I
think okay I miss chess I need to play
chess I will play all tournaments why
not but okay well when I start to play
all
to play all tournaments and now I see it
was big mistake and
I'm really very tight I am very happy
tournaments not finished for me like
catastrophic I mean just as minus two is
absolutely uh normal
results like super tournaments like this
because it's not catastrophe I'm just a
very bad results yeah of course but it
is not catastrophe and I will think of
what to do and I will think how to back
him oh Shaq will of course love you to
have to have you back we'd love to have
you at your Peak because you're such a
fun player to watch thanks for joining
us here at the grantchester this year
thank you very much good luck thanks
thank you Shaq one of those you can play
too much